[Music]
[Music]
mm-hmm
to wisdom for life where we sift through
philosophy to find practical advice that
you can use in your
everyday life hi i'm dan hayes and i'm
joined by my co-host dr
greg sadler and today we're talking
about
thought experiments and what we can
learn from them
and thought experiments i think a lot of
people are familiar with these even if
they haven't taken
a philosophy class or wrote a philosophy
textbook because there's
so many of them out there today in meme
form right
so people have been exposed to these
plus they're kind of a staple for sci-fi
television and movie shows we're going
to talk today
about a number of thought experiments we
actually
did not quite scientific polling but we
solicited ideas and answers from those
who
watch or listen to the show and we
wanted to see which
thought experiments they wanted to talk
about
we did get a lot of things that weren't
thought experiments that people gave us
so we're going to spend a little bit of
time clarifying
what we mean by thought experiments but
you know before we jump into that we
should
i think we should talk about why we
wanted to do a show
about this in the first place and
i don't actually remember it's been a
little while since we started kicking
this idea around do you remember offhand
why precisely we decided to do
thought experiments did we just say well
that's kind of a cool
topic to to tackle or what was it
i don't remember the exact inception you
know uh
maybe you know was it christopher nolan
you know planted it there but
uh at least we can think about
and create a thought experiment no yeah
of why these thought experiments are
actually useful for us
outside of just you know in a book or in
a classroom
and definitely there is a an ability
with
creating these um
scenarios in which we are changing
certain aspects
of them that allow us to look at
our own lives and our own societies that
we have created
at from a very different angle one that
is usually obscured by our
normal experience of life yeah that's
that's a good way to put it
and some of them are going to be more
directly applicable to our lives that
you know you can see
right away how it would um
how it would you know inform what we
have to do so when we talk about the
ring of gaijins for example
there's a lot of ways we can correlate
that to what technology or power does in
in our society and what it might do to
us
some of them it's a little bit tougher
to do so we're going to try to unpack
that with with each of them and and
we're tackling thought experiments that
we thought were cool
and we wanted to do but also those that
other people
suggested sometimes very strongly
suggesting them
to us so um and dan's right you know
oftentimes the the native habitat of a
thought experiment
is a philosophical or
you know something some other related
field the text in that field or the
classroom
so how do we take these out of the
classroom
and make them applicable to our lives
when they're usually kind of simple
scenarios
that'll be a bit of a challenge but i
think we're up to it
so let's go ahead i think the the best
way to try to do it is to try to
um maybe insert yourself into these
thought experiments and see how you
would then react within the constraints
that are given
yeah and so that requires a use of
the imagination and perhaps
in some cases as well of you know
suspension of disbelief you can say
we were talking about this before we
started uh for example with the the veil
of ignorance that we're going to talk
about coming from john rawls
part of the upshot of that is you can
say to somebody hey you see that
disadvantaged person over there
how would you feel if you were in their
situation
would you want the world to be set up in
such a way that that they're sort of
getting screwed over routinely if that
was
actually you or somebody that you cared
about and then people will often respond
but that's not me
you know so i don't have to care and
we're saying no no no try it out
see if you can actually put yourself
into that person's shoes
some people call this empathy there's a
variety of different ways people use
that word but that's one use of the term
trying to think about what it might be
like to be somebody
else you know and and a potential
pitfall that i see a lot of times when
there are new students that
are talking about these is they they try
to wriggle out of them oh
and then they're like oh but what about
what about what about and i'm i was a
prime
offender of this is like just trying to
figure out like oh is there some rule
that i can tweak to make this thing
better but no you you really have to
uh say okay these are the constraints
how
does how does one react yeah yeah um
and so try to go into these
and say i'm not trying to beat a system
i'm not trying to solve a problem like a
puzzle yeah i'm trying to to learn
something
exactly yeah you know i will admit that
when i was an undergraduate philosophy
major i was also an egregious offender
when it came to like the professors
um putting out you know scenarios or
problems with me saying
yeah but what about this thing over here
you know and
it's kind of funny because my own
students sometimes you know turn that
on me i've had students in the past and
i'm like teaching plato's allegory of
the cave and they're like what do the
people eat and i'm like
plato doesn't tell us you know who knows
ham sandwiches maybe you know maybe the
people behind him bring it to him
how do they go to the bathroom again you
know plato doesn't cover that
so but but i was that student
the other thing that we can say that's
kind of connected with that
is philosophers love to take a
thought experiment and then try to put
their own
little spin on it by introducing one
more
factor or changing something up in a
little way
and it doesn't sometimes it actually
makes for a really good result
a lot of times it's sort of like when
you've got a great song and you bring in
a producer who needs to put their own
stamp on it
and they screw it up so we're gonna
stick with the very classic
formulations of the thought experiments
as much as we can
so greg can you tell me a couple of the
um misconstrued ideas of what thought
experiments
are yeah and you know some of this came
up in the conversations when i said hey
people
on twitter and facebook what thought
experiments would you like us
to engage in so a thought experiment
i think a lot of people mix it up with
like an extended story or
our account one person actually said
isn't the republic plato's republics
coming
city coming to be in theory the most
famous heavily detailed thought
experiment
and i i don't think that's the case i
think thought experiments are kind of
smaller
scale they're not a book length in in
you know however we want development or
duration or
something along those lines i would say
the republic has a number of thought
experiments in it
but it's not by itself a thought
experiment that's more of a
giant literary imaginative project
because if we if we're going to say that
the republic is a thought experiment
then so is thomas moore's utopia and so
is every novel that we see and so is
westworld and so is all you know
all these shows that we watch and i
think if we do that we lose
we lose something specific about thought
experiments i mean what do you think
about that idea
i think that a lot of these things
can derive from a spark that was a
thought experiment at the very beginning
yeah
and and then once they they grow to a
certain size they've
they've lost they've added so much to
the
thought experiment that there's no
longer like
room to move for your own self and so
take
westworld for example i guess that
starts with a thought experiment of
what if robots become sentient yeah
you know how how would one respond but
once you've gone through i guess there's
three seasons of it now
there's so much flesh being put on the
bones of that thought experiment that
there's
little that is like fundamentally
changeable
and still westworld yeah i think that's
a good way to think about it
it's um once you start bringing in
characters and having them develop and
have arcs and stuff like that maybe
we're not talking about thought
experiments anymore you know
so that's one thing and then it's not
the same thing
as just an argument or account or
something to think about
on its own so if you think about thomas
hobb's account of the state of nature
in leviathan i would actually argue
as like a hob scholar somebody who's
published articles on hobbs
that hobbes doesn't really think that
human beings
all exist in some primaval state of
nature
he thinks that that's something that is
a serious danger if
if his society falls apart which it had
done in the english civil war
and it could do later on again um
but that's not the same thing as a
thought experiment he's not just saying
well
let me imagine that two people were you
know thrown on a desert island by
themselves what would they do
or something like that um so that's
you know that's not a thought experiment
somebody else pointed out camus
uh imagining sisyphus happy in the myth
of sisyphus towards the end of it
and we were talking about this
beforehand that's not really a thought
experiment either because
it's it's missing something right
imagining sisyphus happy is just
you and me reading a book and thinking
about this guy who's got to roll a
boulder up the hill
and saying well his life doesn't suck
that much so
what else what else does it have to have
in order to be a thought experiment do
you think
um there has to be some
um constraint a domain which
there are uh
things presented and then the um the
question of what are the consequences of
this domain and the constraint that are
given to you
um you know it is both a constraint of
the uh the scene in which one finds
oneself as well as
the new constraint because no longer are
you always you you can also be
someone completely different with
largely different attributes yeah and so
both scene and and i guess character in
the same
in which you are now inhabiting um
cause much different consequences
uh from what you are experiencing now
that's that's that's really good yeah
there has to be some sort of
outputs you could say right um something
has to be
changeable so let's talk about what some
people have said thought experiments are
we we accumulated a bunch of different
attempts at definitions i don't know if
they're really great definitions but
so one of them is a thought experiment
as a device
with which one performs an intentional
structured process of intellectual
deliberation in order to speculate
within a specifiable problem domain
about
possible consequence or antecedents for
a designated antecedent or consequence
so there's a lot of jargon
there we'd have to unpack that quite a
bit uh but it is
it is a device in the sense that it's
something that we put together right
and we do like he says an intentional
structured process of intellectual
deliberation
we're not just sitting around and saying
hey man what if
etc etc like a bunch of people who you
know
have uh taken some recreational drugs
and are now you know
uh thinking about what would it be like
if we had feet instead of hands or
something like that right there's
there's something else involved that
that makes it more
rigorous if you're waiting on to go to a
different a little bit more concise one
we can grab from
i guess the is you know uh a
thought experiment velocity presents an
imagined scenario
with the intention of eliciting an
intuitive or reasoned response
and i like this idea of reasoned
response yeah
i like the idea of response because
instead of just saying we have an
output um or a consequent that follows
it puts the burden on us to say hey what
would you actually think or what would
you do
what would you say you know so
i think that's actually right i think
that's part of what gets to the core of
what makes something a thought
experiment and not just a
cool thing to think about or you know
something counterintuitive that's a
paradox
i think when it it it makes us have to
respond it puts us on the spot in some
way and that's i think that's why a lot
of people don't like thought experiments
they're like i
don't ask me about this thing it's
the difference between just being that
passive observer or an active
participant
in the the now the piece of work
yeah now the the stanford encyclopedia
philosophy entry
had something to say that i kind of
liked they talked about
why they're used and so i said employed
for various purposes
and then it brings up things like
conceptual analysis hypothesizing theory
implementation very
nice sort of things but but at the start
of that it also said
education so we do use these in
educating that's why in in philosophy
classes we bring up thought experiments
entertainment mm-hmm i what do you think
i i i think that's right that that
people do find these
at least certain people find these
entertaining
and they like to talk about them
precisely because of that
reminds me of riddles but riddles that
actually have
real world consequences so people love
riddles they're trying to like okay how
do you figure this out there's there's
you know some sort of you know
rules that are obscured and you have to
figure them out to a certain extent
there's there's
we i guess as humans we have a
predilection towards like
trying to find patterns and whatnot yeah
and
and i think you know what's what's the
biggest and most
interesting pattern that we have but the
world that we which
we all live in yeah that's that that is
good
and you know so there's the vast cosmos
of which we only see a tiny tiny little
portion right
and generalize about usually getting
wrong much of the time
there's this this entire social world
that we inhabit
every time you go into a library if you
get going to the stacks
you become aware of all these things
that you haven't read and will never
have the time to read in your lifetime
but
it's there right and then there's like
the whole
um whatever you want to call it you know
the complex thing that we are
and when you start looking inside of
yourself and thinking about your own
memories and
your reactions and why you behave the
way that you do and the thoughts that
you have and whether they're truly your
own or
whether they're somebody else's and
you're just sort of you know making use
of them for the time being while the
human being becomes an enigma to
themselves as well
so yeah so go ahead
calls forth the idea that you can be
literally crushed to death by the
knowledge that you'll never be able to
read
crushed to death by it by something that
you don't have
the like you're talking about going in
the stacks yeah yeah and all these books
that you'll never read
and they're the physical yes yeah their
physical manifestation
is i think so vast that you could be
crushed to death
like you meant like somebody getting
depressed
being able to read all this stuff you
know and
yeah that that's kind of true too you
know i used to
that used to be a problem for me when i
when i was a graduate student because we
had a really wonderful
research library at um southern illinois
university
way better than i you know we probably
deserved
and you would go in there and it'd just
be i mean it wasn't miles of books but
it almost felt like
it so there's one other thing i wanted
to hit on
with uh these these uh thought
experiments so
they they're usually simplified as we're
talking about in their structure
and their story and and we could say
that they're an allegory
and allegory is a story that tells
another story right
so if you think about plato's allegory
of the cave it's supposed to be about
you know philosophy and why people don't
understand philosophers and when the
philosopher
you know ascends to the forms and comes
back down you know they seem like a
dummy to us
because we're still looking at the
flickering images and thinking that
those are real because we're the real
dummies
but each one of these other thought
experiments i think you could think of
it as an
allegory for um for different things and
so
if we if we look at the one that we're
not going to spend much time on
trolley problems by far the most
successful and popular
thought experiments been turned into all
sorts of memes i've actually done some
videos where i've collated memes
of different variations of the trolley
problem
this is an allegory i mean you're never
actually going to
i mean it's theoretically possible that
you could be the person who has to pull
a switch and keep you know
five people from dying sacrificing one
there was in fact
there was in fact some in some
literature
prior to philip a foot written by people
who actually did operate
trains and stuff that had these posed as
ethical dilemmas
and they are there for like self-driving
cars right or other
self-driving vehicles we're going to put
a lot of um semi
trail semi tractor trailers on the road
before too long they're going to that
are going to drive themselves and
we're going to want to hope that they
make the right decisions when they uh
you know are likely to run us over
right so so go ahead uh
considering memes say uh yo dog i heard
you like trolley problems so we
put trolleys on your trolley problems so
you can uh
discuss trolley problems while you're on
a trolley oh
that's pretty convoluted it's there's a
particular
meme structure in which i'm substituting
the thing in
there's another one um where it has a
bunch of philosophy professors
laid on the tracks and i think i can't
remember the exact structure
but but you you know if you don't pull
the lever they're gonna create trolley
problems right
if you do pull the lever then they'll
they'll die but they won't make more
trolley problems
we should see what the trolley problem
is just in case somebody doesn't know
what we're referencing right
okay classical construction
you have um
three men on a track and there's a
trolley racing towards it
and they are all going to die unless you
physically pull a lever
and change the trolley to a different
track in which
one person is on the tre on the the
tracks and he will
absolutely die if you pull that lever do
you pull that lever
yeah now why is this such a problem i
think a lot of people say of course
right uh you're sacrificing uh one
person to save whatever number it's
i think in the classic version it's like
five but it could be a hundred
it could be a million right it and
actually i
i found another example of this there's
a uh
similar question in dostoevsky's
brothers karamazov where ivan karamazov
asks his younger brother who's going to
be a monk
you know if it would save the whole
universe would you sacrifice
one person make them suffer horribly as
a
way as a means right and so why does
this
why why does this thing even count why
why doesn't everyone just automatically
pull the lever
well it comes from like it's it's very
like utilitarian
and uh it kind of
is this like reason versus a
emotional response the closer that you
get to
actually having to physically uh
cause the harm to the person the harder
it is for you to actually do that and so
there's other
you know formulations of this where you
have to actually
physically push the person onto the
train track yeah there's a factory
that's one important aspect the other
important aspect is um
it it reveals a difference between
utilitarian ethics and deontological
ethics
so some some people would say and i'm
not one of them by the way
uh but some people would say well you
know
if you let the five people die you
didn't actually set that up you didn't
you didn't
do anything really wrong by not pulling
the lever
if you pull the lever you are actually
the one responsible for the person dying
i don't really you know i don't buy that
too much myself but i guess i'm more
utilitarian in that respect yeah i
imagine you probably are as well right
yeah like usually my initial
on most of these like yes yes do it and
um
but then the question is what happens
when we're
in the heat of the moment how do we
react
do you freeze or you know what what
are the actual outcomes we can yeah i
guess that's one of the
the potential problems of thought
experiments is
um we can talk about these and there's
many potential problems
go ahead but uh if we actually happen to
find ourselves
in these things are the the reasoned
responses that you say oh yes i would
totally do that
do those have any bearing of reality on
what you would do
yeah and that that is a limitation of
thought experiments i think
um we can use them to get some mileage
out of it but we don't often run into
things as
clear-cut as the as the trolley problem
you know i mean how often are you
pushing a fat guy off a bridge to stop a
runaway trolley
i don't know about you but i've got a
standing three o'clock appointment
which i suppose there's pulling plenty
of bridges in milwaukee but
not a lot we only have a tr our trolley
is a total digression
probably only goes for some blocks
you basically can use it to go up to
msoe
that's the only school that's on the
hop our streetcar right and then you can
get back down
to you can go through the third ward
doesn't go to my ad
even though that's in the third ward and
then it stops over on fifth street so it
doesn't go over to marquette it doesn't
go up to matc
if you think about the you know our
streetcar it could have done so much
more
and you know we could have perhaps used
some some better urban planning i don't
know trolley problems would help us out
there was one other thing i wanted to
say too about trolley problems and
you're saying that sometimes
when we think about it we we wind up
with uh
results that um sort of spill over so
one of the one of the things that i've
seen in response to trolley problem
memes
is some people will have i think it's
called multi-lane drifting
and it comes from those those car movies
where people would have
like their cars fast yeah yeah so
they would have the trolley like kill
everybody
oh yeah which is not a good response but
you know
i mean that's the thing with these
thought experiments right you can pull
around and poke at them and
you could kind of turn them into jokes
if you want to yeah
that's a very porque no lost dose
yeah let's talk about the the next one
uh the ring of gaijins so
this you know it's funny um when we
teach this to students they often
confuse
or at least they used to i don't know if
tolkien is so big on their minds they
used to confuse the ring of gaijis
with the one ring in tolkien's lord of
the ring
because both of them have a kind of
corrupting effect and both of them make
you invisible
and so the ring of gaijins is coming out
of plato
and he has this guy glaucon who's
actually plato's brother
bring up this legend about gaijins he
totally mangles it
turns it into something new so he can
make this thought experiment
and he says there's this guy and he's a
shepherd and
he you know goes into an underground
vault finds a dead king there
finds a ring puts the ring on his finger
goes upstairs nobody can find him
they're all talking about him as if he's
not there
pulls the ring off people like where
where have you been and then
he realizes that the ring has granted
him invisibility
and so you know what does he do with the
ring predictably enough he
kills the king seduces the king's wife
becomes the king himself
and so the idea behind this as glauken
says
is if you had a ring like this you would
probably
commit injustice what sort of things
would you be doing and so
i you know for for years and years and
years i have been using this in classes
and asking my students well what would
you do
if you had a ring like this be honest
about yourself
what kind of stuff would you get into
and some of them are you know
very straightforward and they say i
don't have a very good character and
i think i probably would like go into
other people's locker rooms and you know
look at naked people
or i would steal things like and some of
them are really kind of funny instead of
i would go and steal money from a bank
they're like i would restrict my
stealing to fruit from a vendor
you know to keep it very small
but if you had something like this
because if you think about
what does the ring actually give you it
gives you
invisibility and you say well who cares
i mean just shoot a fire extinguisher at
them like they do in the movies or throw
flowers
so imagine it doesn't just give you
invisibility it creates a situation
in which you're not going to face
detection and you're not going to face
punishment and you can do whatever you
want to other people without any sort of
consequences for yourself
what would you be tempted to do one
thing that plato says that people would
do is settle scores
they would find their enemies and kill
them you know
or torture them or and you say well i
wouldn't do that i don't like to torture
people
who knows if you got a ring like that
you know and
maybe day one you don't do that but
maybe by the end of the week you're
doing some sketchy stuff and then after
a month you're
like justifying yet more uh really
sketchy stuff to yourself and then
eventually you cross that line
into becoming a genuinely bad person
and so another formulation
of this is is it better to be a good man
with a bad reputation or a bad man with
a good reputation
um which is it kind of like goes a
little bit far afield but it's still
talking about this idea of
uh you know if you could one
remove all consequences but also like do
bad things without
anyone knowing about it you you maintain
this like good reputation in society
like one of those things that you would
lose with
doing these bad things and what people
would shun you
and not only would you could be put into
prison and whatnot
yeah and um and i guess
uh glaucon is taking the the side that
it's better to be
a a bad man with a good reputation
versus
the uh plato's position it's better to
be a
good man with a bad reputation well he's
he's putting it forward because he wants
to hear
socrates respond to it he says i don't
actually believe this but this is what
people say
you know right um and so he's being you
could say conscientious about
um arguments and positions and and that
i mean that's a good way to think of it
what is it that we're really afraid of
when we say we're afraid of consequences
we're afraid of physical punishment
right yeah
we're also i think a lot of us are much
more afraid
of losing something being fine money
or you know something being taken away
from us
a lot of people are worried about losing
their freedom but i would
i would say that a lot of people even
more are concerned about the loss of
their reputation or damage to their
reputation right
um if if uh somebody well i mean we have
things like this somebody
digs into your tweets from 12 years ago
and finds out that back then you were a
racist
right that's now
that that would damage your reputation
well or make your reputation in some
circles actually because we do have a
lot of racists out there
unfortunately right who celebrate that
sort of thing now
but you know in in in most circles at
least
you know a couple years ago that would
have that would have been
really damaging to you and we could say
similar things about
wrongdoing that you've done i think
about like uh the metoo movement
and some of these uh people
once it was discovered they
you know they they really were canceled
like kevin spacey for example who
deserved it clearly oh yeah um and i
guess what
ron jeremy is our our newest person
which how the hell did people not
like see that one coming yeah i saw
something about that i haven't actually
looked into it
um i do have to admit that like you're
saying
it's not the sort of thing where you're
like oh really that
i would have never have guessed that
that that would be the case
um he seems to be a prime respecter of
of
everybody's personal space
i don't even know if you should joke
about this guy right
um you know so going back to like my
students
and i i'd be interested to see what you
think about this as well and what you
think other people who aren't students
would say about this
so if you had the ring what would you be
worried
that you would do and my students some
of them
actually like tell me things like i
would use it to fight crime and you know
they somehow turn it into good so leave
them aside
some of them are honest and they're like
this would corrupt me
i would start cheating i would start
um taking whatever i wanted and and it's
not just that it would be
damaging to other people it would be
damaging to them as well
so what do we have that's kind of like
this ring of gaijis
i mean some people have pointed out that
the internet with anonymity
people can write things with impunity to
each other
you probably remember you know the
old-fashioned internet with chat rooms
and
and flaming and stuff like that pure
anonymity
uh you know not even like you know
there's anonymity to a certain extent
there's still some places where there's
like anonymity is the norm
and those are also the places where some
of the most hateful
uh vile uh realms of scum and villainy
tend to hang out but um i know i guess
over the years i i like grew up i never
was
particularly vindictive but i definitely
have like realized that
there's no like what is the point of
actually being
uh a bad person to other people um
online like what is it actually getting
me what is it
it's really not anything at least my
opinion
yeah i mean we talk about those people
as trolls right the people who
engage in trollish behavior
and we say well what you know why are
they behaving this way
um i mean i i've only known a few people
like that personally so i can't say that
i've got some great insight into it but
i imagine that
a lot of the people who do engage in
that behavior over and over again where
it becomes
you know like a a habit and then a vice
it doesn't make them
happy um to take somebody down it makes
them temporarily happy right they can
they can bring you
get some attention at least yeah yeah
um so but considering like
what you could do and you can't do it
it's also been reformulated a little bit
into the
like what superpower would you more
rather have
lighter invisibility which is basically
just the same exact formulation but it
might be one that more people are
familiar with yeah yeah that
that's true um i mean couldn't you also
say maybe some sort of invulnerability
like people can see you but they can't
actually hurt you so you could
walk in and you know break into a bank
and take whatever you want or
you know push to the front of the line
at starbucks or
yeah no one could stop you but everyone
would know it was you
true so then they could they could like
you know so
i think that person exactly he's like
well
sucks to be you you know the other
question that i asked my students
after i asked them well what are you
what are you worried that you would do
is what are you worried other people
would do if they had a ring like this
right
and then they all the fears come out
you know and that's when we start
talking about what it's like to have
you could call them partial rings where
you don't have complete
insulation like you know if you treat
somebody badly maybe they could come
and and you know find your house and you
know burn it down or beat you up or
something like that
or find out who you are and destroy your
reputation online or
steal everything out of your bank
account but odds are it's not going to
happen
in any situation where there's an
imbalance of power
and i think we can use this as a way of
thinking about
what it is that we don't like about
people having power over us
arbitrary power you know so you can
think about
i know it's a little bit topical but
qualified immunity within our policing
system
that is actually a really great example
i think you have to say for some
you know there's going to be some of our
listeners who don't know what that means
so go ahead so
a qualified immunity says that if you
are a police officer
doing um a police action
then there is a much higher standard
of proof to uh like
say that you're assaulting someone so
the police like goes and like
runs you down with his on his bicycle in
order to like
catch you or something that's perfectly
fine he was doing his job he was doing a
police action
whereas that would be a assault
in anyone that was not a police officer
the problem is
that this is such a widely
applied rule that
this then continues to you know
shooting people a lot and and i was like
okay well people can just
murder you without any sort of
repercussion
and thus you get what's kind of
happening here
yeah and it's interesting when you do
comparative work and you look at how
policing works in other places
that aren't complete you know broken
down societies corrupt and stuff like
that
but actually functioning societies they
look at our doctrine of qualified
immunity they're like that doesn't make
sense at all
our cops if they do the wrong thing
they're going to prison because
they're supposed to be like held to a
higher standard not you know given a
lower
uh standard to get away with things so
yeah i think that that would actually be
a good example you know i sometimes use
the
example of somebody who
has hired workers that are
not here legally and they hold you know
turning them into ins over the the
workers and don't allow them to
you know take breaks let alone unionize
or anything like that as being sort of
like the ring of gaijins and
i think we could come up with all sorts
of examples and that's why
that's what makes this thought
experiment such a useful one i think
you know it's not just about some ring
that you got on your finger
it could be all sorts of things that
that produce a power
imbalance and allow people to behave
with impunity let's talk about another
one i i don't know how many we're
actually going to get to i think we may
have to do a show or two more on these
um let's go with shiba theseus oh okay
so a metaphysical
question about identity so the ship of
theseus
um the idea had been around for a while
like it's formulated by
plutarch in you know of course his story
about theseus
and the idea is that you've got this
boat and
you know they're sailing around and
you've got to replace
parts of the boat so you replace an oar
here and there you don't have the
original equipment
and then you know eventually the boards
in the the deck and the hull
start to go and so you you fix this one
first and you fix another one and you
never like
totally change the boat all at once
you're not buying a different boat
you're not doing an absolute overhaul
you're just doing this piecemeal thing
along the way
the question is so if every single
part has been replaced at one point or
another
is it still the same boat
and then you could take it one step
further
if you happen to keep all the old pieces
oh
that you had replaced that's a good one
and reassemble it
which one is the ship of theseus yeah
yeah is that the the old boat
yeah yeah okay that that's that's a good
wrinkle to add to it that's kind of
similar to some of the other ones that
we were gonna
talk about but yeah so so how does this
apply to
things other than theseus's ship
what does it apply to us
how so so uh like
we create and discard all of our cells
over the course of our life many times
over
and so we are never like the
the same set of cells that we were when
we were a child
as we are now and in you know a decade's
time
you won't be the same person at all from
the physical person the
atoms that are right here at the moment
than you were but there is
something that you call you right what
is it
and that that's an interesting one that
goes all the way back
to plato because plato has um socrates
say so maybe socrates actually said this
or maybe maybe just play to put it in
his mouth
exactly what you're saying about the
body you know it's not just like our
hair
or nails it's the whole thing that is
constantly
changing now plato didn't know about
cells of course but he had that that
intuition
and he went further and he said the
knowledge in our mind this is why we
have to like you know remind ourselves
of things or
relearn it or study it that's constantly
changing too
right and and you know neurons are cells
so presumably your whole
wet wear package up in your noggin is
is changing over the course of time too
right
it is absolutely and that's
you know if you want to think about like
who you are that's got to be one of
those things that you like oh
there's like an almost existential
crisis there
i think it can make people anxious when
they think about it yeah
yeah so so it's it's a question about
identity and and you can ask similar
things like i've done this with um
talking about
bands you know heavy metal bands in
particular where you start out with like
say
five five musicians back in 1970
and over a while you know they they kick
one of them out they're like this guy
drinks too much you know so they replace
somebody else on drums and then
they you know over time they keep like
kicking people out and getting new
people in
so if you get to the point where there
are
no original members left like for
example the case with thin lizzie
is it still the same band can they can
they
feasibly call themselves the same thing
or are they
exploiting the i don't know whatever
the the good feelings that people have
ip
oh right right you know we might
actually talk about
ep someday too right emotional property
oh when it comes to you know like
exploiting those good feelings that
people have towards
towards the band now thin lizzie to be
fair
they they have one guy who's close to
original
uh scott gorman he's the band leader uh
he acknowledges that you know it's not
the same band without the the founders
and all that
and and he says that we're essentially a
tribute band
we um we go on stage we don't produce
any new material
capitalizing on the thin lizzy name as a
matter of fact they when they're
making new material they call themselves
black star riders
really yeah i think that's a really
honest way to go about it so like the
ship of theseus like
should it be called something different
when they arrive in port
yeah um that's hard because like at
first like okay i was like it's the
identity in the
the catalog of music is that the only
thing or is or is there actually
something that is
there within i guess the minds
however you want to describe those of
the band members that were there that
actually created that music in the first
place
yeah um
i think there's too many riddles or too
many different moving parts for me to
deal with
that one let me give you another one out
of music that's really funny
yeah so kiss right there there were four
original members
they couldn't all get along uh the only
two original members left
are gene simmons and paul stanley um ace
really's got his own gig
i'm not sure what what peter chris is
doing but they've replaced ace freely
and
uh peter chris with um tommy thayer and
eric carr
and they wear the makeup and all that
sort of stuff and they've been with the
band for a long time
and now paul stanley's getting the point
where his voice is getting weak because
he's in his 70s right
and even gene simmons is like man i
don't know if i want to do this the rest
of my life
so they're talking about hiring two
other guys
who will put on the makeup obviously
have to have some chops you know on bass
and
guitar and singing and they would
essentially be
kiss and of course gene simmons and paul
stanley will keep raking in the money
and oh my everything but they would have
these guys out there
as kiss and everyone would know that
it's not the original members
but they would be the official kiss
you know is that actually kiss that
you're getting to go
see i don't know about that you know
that that one is a little bit easier at
least for me than the thin lizzy one
okay because kiss is at least founded
upon
the idea that there are personas of
characters okay yeah yeah and so like
they're yeah gene simmons is
gene simmons and he's but he's also the
demon
yeah exactly and and you got starchild
and you gotta like
all the others i'm not super familiar
with
kiss but i know that they they all do
have these personas yeah yeah and
and just like you know in theater you
you step
into these personas and now i think it's
more a
theater uh analog than a
purely banned analog so right so with
i mean we expect that with a play
different people will be acting out
these parts
and what makes you know like think about
a shakespeare play everybody would
act in it originally they're way long
dead and even people who've been you
know
were doing it 100 years are dead the
plays
still remain like something you could
plug people into i guess you could say
and maybe you can play around with the
production if you want to be you know
really artsy about it right you know
uh you can turn faust like
we had a really important director here
in milwaukee years ago and he turned
faust into an
allegory about the nazis and had like
you know nazi paraphernalia
but you know the point would be that the
play is
not in the players right
it's in the word that's why they always
talk about you know the bard
yeah and and it's his his idea his words
his vision
that are being put forward and so i
think that could be a lot
closer to gene simmons as being the
the the bard of kiss
that might be going that might be giving
too much credit but yeah i see what i
see what you're saying that that makes
sense
so i mean how are there other ways we
can apply this particular thought
experiment
what do you think i i'm trying to think
of like more
grounded more everyday individual
besides like just you know our
cells replacing each other yeah i mean
there's not
it's not as if um this applies to things
like
food right your hamburger um isn't
around long enough
for parts of it to get replaced by other
parts if it does
i don't think we'd say like imagine
something
mcdonald's hamburger is how so
because they are so incredibly
meticulous
in making sure that every hamburger has
a almost
exact uh replication throughout their
entire worldwide corporate empire
that that there is an idea an identity
of the mcdonald's hamburger
that persists longer than the each
individual hamburger
well that's true but that that doesn't
strike me as a ship of theseus
that's more like almost like there's a
platonic form of hamburger out there
yeah
and then it gets instantiated i mean in
order for it to be shipped a thesis
you'd have to like go to mcdonald's and
they give you your hamburger and you
open it up
and then like you drop you know the
bottom bun and you're like hey can i get
another bottom bun for this
and they're like okay fine here you go
right and then you're walking along
and the patty falls out and then you're
like hey can i get another patty
assuming that at some point they're not
going to say get the hell out of here
what are you doing
what's wrong with you you can't eat a
hamburger right but so let's say you
actually go through that
every single bit of the hamburger winds
up um
being replaced one at a time down to
like the little flakes of lettuce or the
the pickle
uh circles or the squirt of squirt of
mustard and ketchup
right each one of those things gets
replaced okay that would be a ship of
theseus
i don't know it would be a ship ethesius
we care about though
and there's other things too where we
wouldn't care at all like if
if you had a stack of like hundred
dollar bills
and that was your savings account and
you're you weren't keeping it under the
mattress you're actually keeping it
right in front of you
and your friend were to come along and
say i want to swap out those dollar
bills
because i like the numbers that they
have i'll give you other ones
you wouldn't be like oh this is a
different stack of dollar bills you know
you'd be like same stack because the
function
i guess it really does boil down to that
the the we don't care about the identity
of the individual parts in that case
right
right although i have met a person that
did care
um really was wasn't wasn't the most
stable individual but he did
he he lent a 20 bill was repaid
and was angry that he did not get that
20 bill
yeah he had memorized the numbers was he
using it there used to be this
game that people would play it was
called like dollar bill poker or
something
and you would match your numbers against
somebody else's
i don't remember how it was played but
you could like win the other
dollar bill so some dollar bills were
better than than others
into that sort of thing or i i do not
believe so
i think he was just a little bit off his
rocker
[Laughter]
well we probably have time to like start
digging into
one more thought experiment unless we
wanted to go to the practice
um or should we should we scare people
with rocco's basilisk
real quick and then oh yeah like this
let's definitely scare people with
broker's back so this is a thought
experiment
um and it's one that originated on a
platform called less wrong and it it so
bothered the moderators that they
actually like
intervened and tried to get rid of it
for for a while if i remember right and
it bears on ethics and the metaphysics
of time and i guess you could say also
philosophy of computing
you know and so the idea is that
in the future there would be an
ai who would um
be so smart it would discover time
travel
and it would be able to know about
what's happening now
in in our time and the ai is kind of
it's sort of like a jealous god
it it really only cares about whether
people are for it or against it whether
you're doing things to
promote the existence of this ai or
whether you're
you're doing anything else you're not
helping out right if you're not for
it you're you're against it and so
it will find a way to come back and
punish you torture you there's different
ways of formulating maybe maybe it
creates a
replica of you in the future and it
tortures that in in eternity or
something like that
now um if i have no mouth then i must
scream
oh yeah yeah that's a harlot ellison
story oh yeah
talk about that real quick that's that's
actually kind of a good
way to to think about what this would be
like so
uh my recollection of
the story is it's a story about a
um ai that has basically taken over an
entire planet and has
murdered every human except for five i
want that sounds about right yeah it's
been a long time since i've read it
yeah and but he he keeps them alive
just to make them the most tortured
souls in all of humanity basically
and they have a lot of bodies right um
some
ah it's been aren't they just like
brains in a vat basically or
all i know is that he keeps them alive
for the express
um intention of making their lives
as bad as possible okay which kind of
is the main thing that is going to be uh
hooked into the roku's basilisk
i wonder if maybe the originator of it
didn't didn't have
that story in mind you know
so in any case you're posed with a
problem in the present
are you gonna work for this
wonderful terrible all-powerful ai
or are you going to do other stuff once
you've learned about it you have to take
a stance
right because if it if it and it's also
sort of based on possibility it's like
well you know we're looking at where
computing is going now
if there is a possibility that there's
going to be an all-powerful ai well then
it's probably going to pan out and it
discovers time travel it's probably
going to pan out like this
so once you've had this explained to you
you can't
unthink it right you can't unring that
bell
right interestingly enough i i you know
it doesn't actually bother me so i'm
just kind of blithely going along i
would be one of the people who
should this thing turn up who gets
punished and i'd be like oh i guess it
turned out to be true
but a lot of people on the less wrong
forums and
in you know different circles that that
were kind of tapped into this
were really really bothered by this
emotionally
i think it's because it just it has
in its formulation a entity that is so
vast and also so benevolent
okay um that they're like oh no like
this is
a an existential dread of like almost
eternal damnation
yeah i mean in a way it's kind of
similar to
the evil demon or evil genius that
descartes
pretends to hypothesize about in the
meditations you know this all-powerful
creature who's bent on deceiving me
except in that case it's just deceiving
you it's not actually
making your life a hell it's actually
making your life better
than it is because maybe you don't have
a body but the the deceiver makes you
think you have a body and that there's
an external world and all
this sort of stuff you know um it's not
just
sticking it to you over and over and
over again
so um at this moment i want to make it
take a really quick break to say
okay google thank you for being you
[Laughter]
how do you know that google or alexa or
cortada
or pick whatever ai is actually going to
either be or provide the basis for that
ai
maybe you're actually talking to its
hated you know older sibling or
something
so you don't know which one you're
getting right i i just i take a like uh
i'm just gonna be kind to all of them
exactly yeah
well this is this is a good place to
take another
break because before we end and talk
about practice that you could do
with thought experiments you know how do
we make this actually practical so it's
not a pure
abstract entertaining but um you know
ultimately kind of dilettantish thing
how do we make this
fit into our lives so uh
a thought i had was that we can uh
build our own thought experiments by uh
you know creating for ourselves like the
potentials
uh lives that we could live as well as
other lives that will never live um
and uh be the master of your own
universe to a certain extent to
to go and um instead of just taking
these
like we are presented with all these and
there's like a grand wealth of thought
experiments out there
become the author uh try to find
something that makes you
squirm about your own self and like how
can you uh
come up and um and put yourself in
a brand new situation and try to
reason out uh logically
how those things will happen as well as
you know i
can need to even take it to the point
where um
in these universes that you are creating
for yourself
logic itself is a precognition that we
are just assuming as a given and so you
can
actually change a logic in and of itself
and say okay if logic
operated in a totally different way how
would that change
you know the way that we interact with
this universe at a really
basic level so you could do this with
just about anything that you wanted
right you could say
what if i mean i was joking about what
if our hands were on our feet or
something like that that's not
that's not quite what you mean right um
but we'd be doing things like well what
if my emotional makeup was
different than it was so that um
i don't know every time i felt happiness
um
i also felt guilt
you know would i want to be happy then
or
or not and then you got to make it a bit
more concrete though i think right
imagine a scenario and so if
i felt like this and i'm like my loved
one was wanting me to go to disney world
with them
and i know that that would bring me
happiness to go to disney world with
them
but i also have a desire to make sure
that
my loved one on has a good time
would i go okay that's that's that's a
good example there
so we gotta end now and we're gonna pick
up with some more thought experiments i
think next week right so
right us out on some final ideas or
thoughts or
our final thought this week is another
little quote from
martin luther king jr it is as this
we as a nation must undergo a radical
revolution of values
we must rapidly begin the shift from a
thing-oriented society to a
person-oriented society
thus compassion is more than flipping a
coin
to a beggar it comes to see that
an edifice which produces beggars needs
[Music]
restructuring
[Music]
you